maybe you don't know he won two championships
with Michael aner in Hamilton BS streaking on
the right side shoots tried to pick the short
side nearly did P's to the arm and piece of
the post the crease bson coming that close to
opening it up off the draw one to B controls
rebound off the end boards trying to slap
it towards the that was Mot La shot hanel
off the crossbar down and here's the hanala
post a little walking of the blue line look
at the bodies in front just a seeing ey shot
that would have found the back of the net if
it was on net but it hits the crossbar but they
survived big collision at the Blue Line Tim skler
rolled back wasn't happy thought they a call was
missed derson tries to turn the corner puts it
backhander on and it's been a while for Mar and
he re acquaints himself with that little black
disc and you'd love one of those options to be
Josh Norris absolutely he lost the no contact
Jersey so he's out of yellow but we still don't
really know when he's do back to the maritine
Sydney Nova Scotia Halifax Nova Scotia so you have
to keep in mind the travel in those back-to-back
games it's turned over Johson fii and that one
nearly stuck through now a gaping net they score
Jansen Harkin gets the game's first goal as
wiip TS the lead in the second period watch
The Exchange here he tried to go D to D and comes
right back through the middle of the ice that's
Thomson that pops into the middle of the ice and
gets picked off the exchange right here and you
see marilan does a good job of forcing the puck to
the outside but that the puck comes back through
the middle what a pig climbing a little wind in
their sails now after getting through the first
they find a goal in the second Ottawa trying
to answer Obby jarti back CER scores how about
that for reply jarti keeps his strong pre season
going a this is a little sneaky one a little entry
Little D to D back to the neutral zone turned
over good pressure down low nice little skill
play by Bon garanti looking for options and he's
on the goal line just throws it towards the net
a lot of times a goenda and seal that post seal
the ice you see from this angle right there bris
unable to see high event second period so far was
pretty quiet first period yeah we'll take it yeah
P Knuckles one into the far Corner finds Baron
behind the that back hander right on MAR to that
blocker Post in time they kind of wave into their
next shift stot slip rips it on and equal to the
task against good Outlet pass here by Chan you've
got St gets a outside positioning gets wedged off
no nerves in pre-season I guess just aggressive
confident in this play not problem with that some
room Bon checked up and it redirected good stop
by bris as that one changed on its way in up ice
stla closing in and that one went wide well he
didn't miss by M tried to go short side this time
instead of glove and Mandy who switched out with
mariline is forced into action in a hurry welcome
to the pre-season CH across PS saage has two in
front Spitz to smel bouncing around smle scores
they won't like it as it comes back Jake Sanderson
right there keeping that Pucket beautiful pass by
bson I don't know if they review that it looks
like there is contact between the right skate
and bruis left skate now I don't know if they they
made a glove down play I think that was Stanley
I think that was Stanley that had his glove in
see Tim sluta arguing s still feeling it on the
power play daro down low into the slot and that
one fluttered off a stick lessening the blow for
brwal I was glad that analytics had slid into the
game at that point didn't need a clip clip board
doesn't look like a fun job no F like that was
working here's his steal nice dangle nice goal clo
jeru putting on a show in
the pre-season back hand to
forehand and Drew just a a great
look reads it perfectly puts it underneath the
bar couple starts couple half games mandaly
did the same thing coming in halfway through
the game cold just wanted to fire up the Poke
check called the old fire pokeer get it going
trying to protect that puff down low steals it
off of B the stick centering and there in time
was Roby jenti and jenti might have saved a goal
btis in the other way shs point blank and way
out to stop that here brah Puck's going to come
the other way B little give and go through the
middle of the ice and then bson little curl of
drag tries to go short side shelf and play back
around CH him across gets it back PL it in the
middle good stop man the lazy to take one away
pun PL on Harkin tipped in front man the lazy
stretches out what a stop Rolling Puck empty net
they Scramble for it and somehow through that
yard sail it stays out as mandaly gets back to
the post start to finish good save initially by
mandaly through the the bumper play makes its way
underneath the body through the other side for
a wide open net arkins battling as well a good
left pad offering and a second one the battle
for the puck and then it slides back the other
way samber drops for Lucius Waters part shoulder
stop mandaly from Chad Lucius rebound and Morgan
Baron thought he had that one deposited smel on
it Chan whiffed on that tonado might be home free
onado in shoots stopped by mandaly rebound and
mandaly got that as well from B wrong play doesn't
get opened up as he pushes across there's ice
coverage there's also five hole coverage on the
play Johnson fi couldn't get it
out Ottawa Shabbat to the side
Flipper on in transition by baon and bran
stands his ground sends take advantage
of it hold the line right through the
seam thrown towards net back door and
Bap lost control Deep In the Zone Morgan Baron
hustling around Shabbat around another Baron and
last line of defenseman the lazy stop to highlight
real play K shank tied up off the draw however and
the Jets get a good opportunity right C Den n
by Mand lazy and he'll stare it out of the air
as well thrown to space skate right into it
the initial save and then batted out of the
air by Gerson I don't know if that would have
been high stick or not but man as he reach of
[Applause]
stla stla now has an empty net WS it
over however and teraso scores to ice it
[Music] that's Fran from a little
we talked about snooker Billiards
however you want to term it little Bank
play off the wall into space for szla
little backhand saucer a little smile from
the newcomer and Ottawa it's another win
in the pre-season as we inch closer to
opening night a 3-1 victory over WI back